the mediterranean sea a graveyard again  for at least 300 african and middle  eastern immigrants trying to reach  europe in frail boats this call from the  parliament  continent the same day by chance meps  debated the future of the external  border service frontex and the european  asylum support office more must be done  to assist member states who receive  large numbers of migrants and more must  be done by the commission to ensure  those countries where migrants first  arrive can properly deal with them as  soon as they arrive  in the right conditions  and here by the instruments  the un says three and a half thousand  people perished in the mediterranean  last year exacerbated after the italians  disbanded their search and rescue  operation mary nostrum to be replaced by  the triton border controlled  meanwhile many meps feared deaths would  increase especially when the summer  approaches